what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to do a movie reaction
today for Starship Troopers that's how I imagine
they say it John how are you I am doing well
how are you Greg doing great that's how I
imagine I say that it leaves my Paramount
Plus subscription in 10 hours so I was like
well we gotta knock this off the list then
full disclosure I'm pretty sure when I was
like seven years old so like 25 years ago
I saw some of this movie needless to say I
can't tell you anything about it other than
I'm pretty sure they kill a lot of big bugs
in it so it's pretty much gonna be like a
first time watching for me essentially but
John you've never seen this at all right no
I've seen some of the effects pieces in person
but that's about it yeah it's gonna be a fresh
fresh film fresh film yeah because I know
my dad really liked this movie I caught it
in the background in his own frame I experience
growing up with it the latest gentlemen leave
a like that'd be very much appreciated uh
that would that would help us out I guess
also subscribe click the notification Bell
we got more movie reactions rolling out we
are out of town at the moment and so we will
be back to the 20th so we're just kind of
trying to stockpile though the list of things
we did not cover and uh full length Reaction
watch along as we sync up with your own copy
of Starship Troopers available for super sexy
rejects on our patreon page major major thank
you to all who have helped us have great holidays
by supporting us on our patreon let's get
into action people
young people from all over the globe are joining
up to fight for the future doing my part I'm
doing my part I mean my part too oh God
source of the bug meteor attacks orbits a
twin star system whose brutal gravitational
forces produce an unlimited supply of bug
meteorites in the form of this asteroid that's
horrifying we break neck now and take you
live to clendafield where the invasion has
begun
a planet
crazy it's like some Pitch Black [__]
yeah that's kind of like the muto from Godzilla
wow what an opening
[Music]
I just go right into the camera it's like
a found footage movie
this is a Paul verhoven movie right yeah okay
Rico Rico Rico pay attention and pH damn we
talked about the veterans how they took control
and imposed the stability that has lasted
for Generations since you know these facts
but if I taught you anything of value Denise
Richards wow she's so ugly
the contrary opinion that violence never solves
anything is wishful thinking at its worst
people who forget that always pay Suave I
doubt anyone here would recognize civic virtue
if it reached up and bit you in the ass
you'll never get together now she was so ugly
I heard this movie was gross but geez
good job my God
yikes it's embarrassing
cool
insect Society by human standards they are
relatively stupid but what have the bugs done
do they attack us the heart no gloves on anybody
a solid barf gag she just got hot
kink but Cyrano
go bug mom Cyrano go bug mom to go eat it
I sure hope you don't do anything like that
to me can't do human yet Neil Patrick Harris
you are problematic oh my god future football
yes
wow it's the XFL everyone's going to the dance
aren't you well let's go over tomorrow you're
going to the fleet Academy
[Applause] not Bill Paxton you are hitting
on her [Applause]
ow damn that's a very colorful film say Buenos
Aires tigers
Denise Richards you don't give two [__]
you're drifting
got it get your head in the game this was
in friends as a reoccurring character [Applause]
can't get over that it's so cool it's the
coolest flips are cool
let's go Casper Vending [Applause] that's
right you still have a girlfriend I'd rather
take 10 Lashes in Public Square than see you
ruin your life it's a term of service I just
want to get out on my own into space and a
war
god that is a conflict which one do you go
for depending on who the camera's on I think
she's the better looking no Johnny how come
we never been together can we just be friends
this
dude friend zone Troopers well my parents
are against it what would you do if you were
me figuring things out for yourself is the
only Freedom anyone really has use that freedom
make up your own mind Rico he told me to make
up my mind so that's what I'm gonna do [Laughter]
what are the bugs doing though you know there's
just existing they're inflicting tyranny are
they they're taking our jobs Gene what are
they doing here this is the address yeah we
know each other from the game well maybe I'll
see you at the Academy yeah who knows do you
know you would go for that guy with that haircut
he looks like Chris Catan militaryism great
thing it's a great thing dude I love Wars
authoritarianism great thing great things
thank you I'm gonna be a pilot for you got
games in theory
Game Theory it's a game Game Theory let's
make a vow no matter what will always be friends
your friendship at risk yeah man that's what
the bugs are doing tearing us apart no we're
Zion that's all there is to it it may look
bad but if that's the worst you suffer then
that's fine I won't quit [Laughter] it's my
decision I made it you walk out that door
you are cut off young man you understand me
all right that's it you are cut off I love
this definition distinguishing Citizen and
civilian yeah I'm gonna miss you I'm gonna
miss you too I love you
oh that's me no ouch
[Laughter] just like that high school's over
[Music] fully automatic burrito wants to hold
it citizen rule [Music]
yes right over that gun
it's hilarious every school kid knows that
her records are dangerous
good censorship the antenna had already been
chosen by other colonists arachnids would
you like to know more that's enough for one
day definitely some RoboCop in this movie's
DNA [Music]
plants are brown yeah buddy who thinks they
got what it takes to knock me down yeah I
do sir that's the spirit
ouch you go that far you're right son sir
yes sir it's smart ow oh so dumb who's next
reporting for Duty sir no way Pacific living
requested transfer from Fort Cronkite to this
training unit sorry
stock makes youth
that's the kind of guy who makes squad leader
that's my job you're talking about Street
Fighter no she looks like Cami
nicely done Clancy Brown Colonel guile wins
I joined up to get out on my own and you had
to tag along I joined the mobile infantry
because of you you're saying you didn't I'd
be honored Rico hi
much better thanks squad leader Rico then
I got you don't know it isn't about that it's
about who's the best hey
ah there's your squad leader
what are you doing yes
worst form of trading uh he gonna remember
that the enemy cannot push a button if you
disable his hand
you know Rico from Buenos Aires what's his
story it's here because of a girl these people
just not have sex drives what's going on here
everyone's used to the human anatomy in this
future sometimes I think I won't make it but
then I think about what you're doing then
I try harder
it's not the first take of that butt shot
you guys this is like the perfect right wing
world fascistopia I love it I still don't
know what the bugs do that's really that bad
you know other than exists existing
Andy's got such like a pristine Sheen to it
all I love it
deploying wings it's terrifying
sweet Elysium [Music] now this is POD racing
how come you're in such a good mood huh because
today I get to fly that Dizzle what are you
doing here I'm the guy who's gonna teach you
to flatten this crate already
scrape your Fender three meters from object
[Music] I bet you're greatest hundreds of
people oh just do it don't exceed Port speed
or what or they revoke your flight status
and
your career is in my hands
how does it feel
are they really getting shot I think they're
getting electrocuted
she's clearly the one for you man man they're
defending
me whole play and you can score cover me you
could score Flip Flip
[Music] wow [Music]
thanks buddy [Music] oh yes dual wielding
double fist in [Music] flag captured Rico
wins I couldn't have done it without you [__]
friends
yeah you playing the long game
hi Johnny God this is so hard who do you go
for flight this is the real conflict of the
movie
up with him
I mean Johnny let's give him some space guys
what kind of right-wing [__] is this she
should be settling down with him kill all
those bugs this is not a satire anymore go
with the backup this what are you doing today
fire team with me next team in 10 seconds
expect you to do better burhoven has such
an interesting way of doing political commentary
I know it just it just creates the world and
commits to it and doesn't even like talk about
it just lets the world demonstrate itself
yeah
[Music]
it's my helmet it's all screwed up don't take
it off Disney put what's the problem whenever
something goes wrong it's always you don't
take your helmet off dude oh no oh [__]
that's damn ain't no medic for that Rico did
you give the recruit permission to remove
his helmet sir yes sir Breckenridge reported
a helmet malfunction and I asked him to show
it to me sir are you rated Hank
Sergeant we've already lost two recruits over
this incident I'll be back we'll try administrative
punishment oh put him in the stocks
I'm gonna whip him this is a very entertaining
movie yeah for failure to abide by safety
regulations during a live fire exercise for
negligence which contributed to the death
of a teammate black man whipping the white
man hey hell yeah ten lashes
they carry out the sentence oh they all have
to be present for it [Music]
I'll try not to enjoy this too much yeah and
lashes geez there's a gravity field out there
gravity at 225 and Rise report captain we're
in the path of an unidentified object moving
toward us at high speed profile suggests an
asteroid ma'am
oh yeah let's get some bugs in space [Music]
oh dang
50 people just died contact please tell them
there's a loose asteroid headed their way
Communications are down ma'am they're gone
oh no I was hoping it would be all right if
I came home come home
and meet I'm sorry I've been in need I don't
talk like that you just come on home talk
things out I'll tell you I told you so we
love you son oh they're gonna get killed aren't
they yeah
he's got to get motivated somehow Millions
there a city in Ruins is that Geneva the meteor
was shot out of orbit By Buck plasma that
derived from clendathu the arachnid's home
planet [Music] God thank God they were away
yeah yeah [Laughter] Buenos Aires has been
wiped off the Earth wowie to ensure that human
civilization not insect dominates this galaxy
now and always yes dominance is the key your
basic arachnid Warrior isn't too smart but
you can blow off a limb
it's still 86 percent combat effective here's
a tip aim for the nerve stem and put it down
for good his hair is not as blunt I'm from
Buenos Aires and I say kill them all yeah
I feel like we've maybe we've seen so much
Doctor Who I'm just like I just don't feel
like the Bucks today I know they just need
a habitable home world where they won't fly
into ours at random like are they really that
bad Xander you remember Johnny this is the
part that's best for both of us Johnny wait
I didn't forget a lieutenity's mobile infantry
you got something to say about the mobile
Infantry think you heard me you want to make
something of it yes football do it shirtless
football come on what's he gonna do
[Applause] come on
mobile infantry and Fleet don't mix doomed
from the start [Music] this movie has an insane
production yeah man this looks gorgeous it's
like so many costumes and set pieces
straight man I thought this move was gonna
be them mainly just killing bugs I know but
there's so much more commentary than I expected
yeah I mean most all the bug kills thus far
like an hour if we haven't even got into them
yeah they're all in either like laboratory
settings or propaganda videos yeah [Music]
cheese man still looks great drop is 35 complete
man
wow [Music] oh someone made a mistake oh no
get out of there oh yeah that's chaos
whoa
a lot of dead humans look at all these extras
my God they're they're just running right
into battle oh is this the beginning of the
movie was I mean it looks kind of like it
although it's much darker than that was [Applause]
up
holy God that is terrifying
[Music]
[Music] wowie because you ain't got to worry
about radiation in this future [Music] fire
oh [__]
wow looks really hard to kill them got an
aim at the nerve cortex that is so many bugs
what are we doing I don't know
oh yeah sure why not do that that's a strategy
more than just yourself killed
oh my God [Music] thank you [Music] God I
would just rely on grenades oh
oh no she was so nice Glenda
[Music] this is flat this is worth a [__]
so fast play it get out of here
let's keep filming just keep filming whatever
the people the world needs to know that's
clever to get it on the other side I'll buy
that for a dollar I love that the camera man
I think it's great to get that perspective
of the cameraman yeah just like get that shot
get out of here now that was Casper Van Dean
at the beginning
oh man
yikes oh
foreign
bugs frankly I find the idea of a bug that
thinks offensive [Laughter] is small-minded
man what's going on with that whole psychic
thing that's got to come in especially with
the hive mind idea [Music]
it's all your fault
why they declare Rico deceased he's right
here Star Wars that's cool see you later bye
oh oh
that was a nice three days in there sounds
relaxing hopefully the bugs don't come in
and destroy it all you want the job huh I
wouldn't mind that guy's a walking dead so
I hear you lieutenants are real nut Buster
oh that would be you no one talks about the
lieutenant that way saved my life mine too
oh he's the priest yeah yeah
who's that iron inside yeah
[Music] everyone fights no one quits you don't
do your job I'll shoot you
they were just trying to have a parade just
now that's all there's marching through town
they're just doing their thing did I miss
some line in the beginning tells you why they're
so bad like yeah you interacted and they're
gonna kill you but it's just like leave them
alone
much easier to kill them during the day [Music]
[Applause]
it was screaming I was in pain guys don't
waste your bullets it takes like 4 000 bullets
to kill one and you guys clearly just take
the spray approach
that is a nuclear rocket
I got
[Music]
oh oh here we go
you need another nuke oh yeah I remember that
shot from the trailers when I was a kid I
did remember that shot
oh no no that's your punching arm no I liked
her get on top of him that's smart
learn to ride it
it's like a boss level yeah it really doesn't
make a great arcade game [Music]
Jam a nuke down in [Music] hurry up Rico get
off there
that's far enough away [Music]
oh yeah oh he's not getting disintegrated
that's for Buenos Aires yes
I need a cork you're it until you're dead
or do I find somebody better promotion what
about this looks like I'm your girl sir
I do have great chemistry all three of them
they should have a three-way [Applause] have
fun sir yes sir come on Corporal ah no I don't
do that anymore I remember when you used to
Dance come on do I have to pull ring oh come
on man you once asked me for advice you want
some now yes sir never pass up a good thing
I've been watching you since school and you're
an idiot son [Music] finally
get that Casper Van dip [Music] I love you
Johnny [Music]
oh he didn't say it back you're moving out
there's been his best golf in general one
on planet P so get your [__] wired and
report in 10 minutes yes sir who's that with
you Glory sir make it 20 minutes
Wing Man of the Year in contact with General
Owen no sir not even the transponder signal
it's these Canyons go to Higher Ground sir
all good Wings this is roughneck 2-0
I feel like you straight up sacrificed that
guy
[Music]
mercy kill I'd expect anyone in this unit
to do the same for me
will I would love to be in this war
gross jeez dirty bugs came in right well they're
having ciao oh really what does that look
like to you Rico oh like a bug was in his
brain sir oh you just put your [__] hand
in there oh that's blood already sucked his
brains out
Jake Busey did not sign up for this we should
just shoot me
just a little out of his mind sir space dementia
those are cool outfits yeah the helmets and
all that stuff like that's a lot of bugs
no that's an impossible situation
[Music] oh those got to help
that is so many bugs how does this all look
as good as it does [Music] oh no [Music]
oh wow
I know ammo has never been an issue [Music]
yeah yep Yep this place called sir we need
pickup now watch your position come down on
this transmission so The Outpost that's crazy
I hope you have a crazy pilot ow you have
a crazy pilot [Music]
Christ
oh my God this is an impossible situation
it's a nightmare
further
[Music] so yeah we're way faster
feel that slash yeah oh
guys just let him go just get the get out
of there what are you wasting your time for
that's a crazy pilot they ain't covered fire
fall back this is the rescue
hold on
Michael Ironside oh why are you always Dying
Michael iron son oh my God
nah you're gonna have to kill him dude put
him out of his misery he remembers orders
nice
[Music]
oh damn foreign [Music]
oh
she's getting a painful ass death
put her in the back to tank she'll be fine
no come on she's the best [Music] let's go
get a board [Music]
you too [Music]
damn it oh jeez that's horrific Johnny I'm
done
no you're gonna be all right this oh man because
I got to have you oh oh that's really sad
say it back buddy [Music] oh no that is sad
maybe Denise Richards will take him back especially
now she's concerned about his feelings it's
her Duty attention on dick wow she's getting
like a full-on funeral representative of all
the soldiers no one gets a full-on funeral
[Music] Burial at space [Music] Jesus
[Laughter] and every day I have to make decisions
that send hundreds of people like you to their
deaths that's what the mobile infantry is
good for going back to pee capture that brain
you're still gonna be friends everyone fights
no one quits don't do your job I'll kill you
myself do you get me
welcome to the roughneck Rico's Roughnecks
alliteration [Music]
they really should plan better they've been
through this yeah like come on guys what does
a brain bug do it controls them all it's like
the queen it's the hive mind yeah
no all of his love interests are going to
die [Music] wow that's horrifying
damn the details yeah that's beautiful [Music]
oh bummer oh she's dead
[Music]
Space Mountain
foreign
[Music]
you breaking up [Music]
oh get out get out what's your name address
and birthday that's right hey good all right
let's go let's rock and roll now 42 East 118
situation is I repeat
the situation is extremely hostile
here we go whoa [Music] [Applause]
[Music] [Applause] foreign
bug sucks out the brains does it like take
all the memories and everything I guess it
seems like they're yeah they're like learning
sort of how to anticipate what the humans
will do and learning what the humans want
she's still alive how do you know I don't
know how I know but I know [Music]
roughneck 2-0 proceed on Mission I need two
volunteers
buddy the main the main people will leave
who assumes command
yeah uh that is disgusting I'm pretty sure
I've seen an image of this creature before
I have seen this creature in person before
have you yeah damn what effects house was
that
it's so cute oh my God that is disgusting
I feel a little nauseous
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
oh my God
sweet darling yeah [Music]
that knife throw it throw it yes
should not be used that hand [Laughter] she
would not be holding up her arm like that
says it's way too much not armed she's not
even like responding
foreign
[Music] oh no no walking dead priest guy
[Music] order
Duck and Cover why would you stop to look
stop stop
saved by a cave-in life made the decision
for him got rid of that one guy got rid of
that girl man now they're both Carmen
oh no
ah poor guy it's in pain it's a Fray yeah
foreign we are terrorizing these creatures
xenophobia fear is the ultimate power [Applause]
the drill instructor named Zim who captured
a brain hey good for him thank you sir that
would be private sir here I am private yes
sir we had to get the voter to go to combat
that's that's that's kind of neat Federal
scientists are working around the clock to
probe its secrets
we will defeat it [Applause] this is the captain
speaking soldiers like private Ace Levy and
lieutenant John Rico [Music] dope Paul verhoven
wow that was fun that was a delight that was
a movie that was cool what'd you think John
I I was uh a roller coaster ride that was
quite enthralling is yeah like you said I
I guess I it it out at the outset I expected
something more along the lines of like you
know the third act but for the whole movie
so I I appreciated how much they let you live
in this world and how it sort of just presents
everything to you and sort of leaves it up
to you to kind of interpret how it's you know
coming at the material because I think this
is based on a book and I think the book is
said to be a lot more unironically what this
movie is doing um but yeah uh I had a blast
this was fun from from start to finish and
I appreciate the sly way in which Paul verhoven
Works in his commentary to these different
movies and I thought the cast was great too
the cast was great Casp Casper Van Deen man
where's Casper Van Deen why is where where's
the Casper science gonna gonna happen um well
the recommendations on Amazon are Starship
Troopers 3 which seems like Casper Van Deen
returns yes that's the one older yeah Starship
Troopers invasion Starship Troopers traitor
of Mars that's like an animated movie where
he looks like snake pliskin I I feel like
maybe they lost sight of the commentary I
haven't just became about I have an absolute
feeling that this franchise became what the
first movie was trying to comment yeah yeah
yeah totally is I I don't know I have I have
no idea but it's just impression that I'm
sort of because yeah it's one of those things
where if it feels satirical um but also in
the in the kind of like kind of like RoboCop
um there's a lot of Robocop in here yeah but
kind of like how RoboCop has a commentary
but it doesn't treat it with a wink at the
audience in a way it's almost like he made
a propaganda film yeah you know yeah and I
think that's kind of the the cool approach
to it because it's also like an entertaining
cheesy campy movie like there's a lot of ways
you can look at it as like just a fun sci-fi
movie that is as much as it's like a propaganda
it's like it deals with all kinds of things
of like fascism there are certain words I
have the hardest time pronouncing authoritanianism
authoritarianism yeah yeah and military conquest
uh yeah though those words militarism militarism
yeah militarism and and the way we like recruit
uh people so young I mean I guess it helps
that all these high school seniors look like
their college seniors but uh but yeah well
they had a good gloss to it with everyone
it was like the perfect world of what you
know uh and if if I wasn't aware I don't think
it would have any I don't it's only more obvious
to me because I'm aware Paul verhoven made
it yeah yeah versus you're like I didn't know
it I'd be like what is this like yes this
saying this is cool or I might have just picked
up on the Sci-Fi stuff um whereas like the
propaganda stuff I'm like like really is the
commercials that that make it that really
shine a light that this is a a satire commentary
on it yeah they bring the irony front and
center especially by the end when you have
like even bigger bigger shinier titles and
bigger shinier ships and guns and then they're
like torturing this creature you know with
all this triumphant music playing like I think
that that kind of highlights what's happening
under the surface well also the the other
than Neil Patrick Harris the characters are
likable and they don't seem that bad they
don't seem like bad people you know what I
mean so as much as there's the commentary
on it which is something I might just go into
the form the societal conditioning and the
influencing of the mindset you know uh sure
it can whereas like freaking Neil Patrick
Harris is like straight up turning into like
experimental Nazis you know uh but look Casper
Van Dean and um I don't know that actress's
name I swear I've seen her a thousand times
though yeah I mean I've been trying to place
it this whole time at a role in friends of
Rick she was in a play with Joey Tribbiani
oh snap she's great yeah um yeah I I thought
she was awesome and I like I like the tone
of it a lot it's really funny and self-aware
and and I even enjoyed Denise Richards Dina
Meyer Dina Meyer oh yeah yeah Denise Richard
is good too in this that's right she's in
birds and she's she's jigsaw's wife that's
or no no not jigsaw's wife she's she's the
she's uh massage she's like the one of the
investors oh yeah she gets killed she gets
that horrible uh yeah three uh spoilers if
you were planning on binging it dies in three
they're going I swear you're inside but I
can't I can't quite I don't yeah yeah yeah
yeah um and a bunch of other faces you've
seen a thousand times I like the relationship
between the the core three it's like a fourth
guy there but I don't really remember much
better like Jake Bucy Dita Meyer Dina Meyer
and uh I like the chemistry between them I
like the 90s High School romance love triangle
situation going on I thought that was fun
and yeah the effects still hold up really
well like it's gonna this looks incredible
killer production design this looks amazing
for when it was made like this this is It's
a testament to real movie Magic to me because
this was like watching Jurassic Park again
or something where you're sitting there going
like man the budget must have been insane
but you also know exactly where to put Miniatures
you knew where to put your physical effects
you knew how to reuse all those corpse bodies
really cleverly without calling too much attention
to it and then when the CG needs to be there
for the most part it looks pretty great like
the only real CG effects where I was like
this could be a little bit better is when
you know like the brain alien at the end is
so like Smooth I feel like those textures
maybe don't read as well but for the most
part like it's it's really well assembled
but it doesn't pull me out of the movie It's
I'm aware because because the movie's so cheesy
too that it so I mean it's a real movie still
it's still a real film it's not I I thought
I was just walking into pure cam Fest sure
you know not that I'm like oh this is a real
serious thing uh yeah I just thought I was
gonna walk into it because when I heard it
was two hours in like two hours that's a long
time and I feel like it's a little I still
feel like it's a little too long a little
light look it's like it could have been like
20 minutes or later yeah yeah um but I I still
think that they they made an actual film where
I was invested in the story and I I did kind
of care about the characters for the most
part like I was really bummed when Dina died
when you got killed I was like what that sucks
that really bumped me out yeah no absolutely
like like they're good at making you root
for them and I think they they did wisely
to pull in a a classic story uh because you
know it's like you're I think it's part of
the greater soup of what's happening in a
movie like this where like yeah especially
it doesn't betray its perspective we are humans
watching this so we're watching it from the
human perspective so they're going to have
endearing relationships and they're going
to be in different qualities to them and I
think making it that you're spending most
of your time with these private characters
and you're watching as um as Rico gets promoted
through the ranks but you know you're on the
ground level and I think that bolsters it
like you said is feeling like an actual movie
like it's treated like an actual war movie
but yeah you have like the just the right
amount of Camp to sell the heightened sci-finess
of it all without it being silly and I think
too they use like the fact that uh the the
Denise Richards character uh Carmen is you
know becoming a pilot on this ship that looks
exactly like an imperial ship from Star Wars
like is uh I feel like those little things
help to kind of again betray what's really
going on but I think it's a good choice that
they don't betray the characters too much
by overriding them with the author real you
know perspective of you know the the themes
and stuff like that not to say it's like I
feel like this is a movie that has a lot of
those themes on hand but it's not like a hundred
percent committed to being like no this is
an allegory that's going to teach you something
about fascism and how the mechanics of the
military-industrial complex work like it's
commenting on that stuff but it's also yeah
like you said having fun it's also really
imaginative it's also really well constructed
like it's a little bit of everything and that's
I think what makes it so satisfying is because
then on top of all that you can go oh wait
this actually does have something of a brain
underneath all the machismo and all the goo
oh I think I think the the insightfulness
of what they're commenting on is is kind of
resonant throughout the whole movie right
down to Casper Van Dean's Rico character just
the evolution that he has of someone wanting
to like spoiled rich kid who wants to join
the military to make something of himself
and then the way his the way he morphs over
time into the cold-blooded perfect Soldier
by the end of the weird side yeah it's cool
like it's not cool it's it's sad it's fleshed
out and how they did it but what I like about
the approach is if it's made in a way that's
not demonstrating that it's it's a clever
film because it's not it doesn't feel like
it's pro-war and pro-violence no and because
if in fact in a lot of ways it's it kind of
feels like it's the opposite of that yeah
yet they make it in the way they execute it
was to make it like it's a pro war movie well
so that's what's smart about it yeah like
there's so much that is really cool and and
you have all these great little uh interstitial
propaganda pieces and news items to bolster
the that attitude but when you're really in
the midst of the fighting it it's pretty hellish
like you know for as height as it is like
more to them coming out yeah it sucks like
those battle scenes and and the gore gags
and the way people are getting mangled and
mutilated and disintegrated and melted and
like it's it's it's pretty nasty and then
when you get to the end you have the brain
sucker alien like it's really gross and icky
you know so I feel like they they knew where
to put the real fun stuff and it's still fun
as a viewer to watch you know the military
action when it really takes hold but I feel
like those scenes especially aren't played
for fun and that's part of why it it works
it's like it's one of those I feel like movies
before a certain point with messaging and
I guess you know ham-fisted movies have always
existed but I feel like this is one that kind
of allows you the viewer to pick that up or
not you know in the way it portrays things
so you could probably watch this and be laggy
yeah let me go enlist right now you know but
you could also watch this and be like what
did the bugs do though you know I mean I was
watching it the whole time going what did
that what did the bugs do I don't know what
the bugs did that were so bad to it's so bad
that we have to go across space to go and
wipe them out and I understand that yeah it's
like they've got these little meteorites hurling
our way but I'm like look at all this technology
we could easily deflect one of those you know
we could deal with that you know yeah it seems
like it's like we we want the violence and
that's kind of what they're learning in the
school yeah yeah it's like we want it we want
the violence I think there is an interesting
commentary to be had here but it's also if
you want to just watch it as like a fun like
exploited flick I think you can do that too
because it is a fun movie that's the magic
of verhovah yeah I know RoboCop has that for
sure and show girls and Showgirls especially
he knocked it out of the park there that's
why I made a bunch of films following Showgirls
uh yeah no I I think did he do Basic Instinct
too is that him maybe he's please come back
I want to say I forget which ones he's done
because I don't know if it was imitative phase
against it because he's like I'm like watching
this made me miss okay so he's he's done some
some stuff recently but like this made me
miss maybe change their [__] around how's
this working yeah it doesn't separate things
quite as intuitively he did do basic NC yeah
okay yeah yeah yeah like Total Recall yeah
if I wasn't so sure he was liberal well yeah
he's great at taking the end RoboCop for the
first time I saw that I had a similar experience
where I was expecting like oh this is just
gonna be cool you know this is just gonna
be some cool schlocky hyper violent police
Thriller but you know like the police are
also a problematic organization and that movie
doesn't shy away from that or the interplay
between you know uh uh the worst parts of
capitalism and you know force and Order and
all those things and and this also does that
like I loved the distinction between uh what
is it Citizen and uh civilian civilian yeah
and the way that they're using that in school
almost as a sociological sort of thing uh
but using that as the seed to you know indoctrinate
these kids you know that whole thing about
it actually discouraged me you know like really
kind of uh uh creating this enticement of
these kids through that and then you hear
the I think that Motif has echoed again when
they say like you know Consignment guarantees
citizenship and your conscription you know
like joining up guaranteeing citizenship and
I feel like immediately I thought like oh
okay you join our military we will make you
a citizen but no no no it's actually legitimizing
you as an already canonized citizen you know
like this is the way to be a true citizen
is to be a patriot is to go out and fight
you know yeah and it's clever now the movie's
very I thought the movie was really clever
and I thought it had uh some cool action in
it infinite amount of bullets that you just
spray relentlessly it's like non-stop never
reload I thought the costumes were really
cool too oh dude those helmets and yeah the
the especially the battle gear sick yeah it
was really it was it was cool it was it was
not exactly uh what I was expecting no not
at all actually yeah like the last half it
was um and I was more I was more into it the
first half and I was the last half at least
because it's a really well realized world
and yeah I enjoyed going through all the different
you know you'd go through all the different
uh institutions and ranks and places in your
your seeing so many pockets of how Society
exists now and two like they're from you got
all these people with these like Hispanic
names who are all these like white kids and
stuff so like it had an interesting I I almost
wanted to know more about how the world works
now because you know it seemed like the country
boundaries weren't the same as they are in
our version of the world so it seems just
like an it's one of those movies too where
the world build uh without having to do all
of it in a very in your face way like there
are just details about the world that are
interesting that again are yours to catch
or not catch and uh and yeah it's like part
of me was like I want to spend time just sort
of knowing what Earth is like in this day
and age because yeah their designs were really
interesting what was the the so the book itself
is supposed to what were you saying earlier
that stood out to me that the book itself
is supposed to be more um like it's sincere
in it and this is making the movie took the
approach of of mocking it in a way or making
fun of it in a way yeah kind of warping it
inside out and making it a commentary on the
kind of fascism the book was essentially demonstrating
you know a more straightforward sort of way
is how it's always been been broke down to
me now that I've seen the movie you know I'm
sure there's a very in-depth you know video
essay about that but that's always what I've
been sort of eluded by other people so here's
a fun fact for you from imdb oh let's do this
um that uh
uh ver Hoven and cinematographer josta vacano
shot the co-ed shower scene in the nude themselves
on a dare from Dina Meyer what uh on the day
of the shoot for Hoven I have asked to cast
to a little fashion show without fashion so
that can get comfortable being naked when
the cast is reluctant to disrover Hoven asked
them what the big deal was to which my responded
Paul if it's no big deal why don't you do
it quite unexpectedly verhoven got undressed
as well as vicano who had been raised in a
nudity Camp after an initial shocked then
van Dean reporter yelled oh God Dino why and
a good laugh from the cast The Scene was sold
without problems that seemed so distracting
because I feel like half of you guys have
to be like super horny right now we are not
your young blood or showering a bunch of attractive
woman right like you created somehow the most
mature shooting environment because none of
us watching this either able to be like nope
this is normal which good for them in the
future I guess uh uh you know uh sexual sociology
and politics are much more calm in this future
because yeah they got co-ed everything oh
here we go there's an interesting quote um
why are you doing a right-wing fascist movie
verhoven was asked he replied if I tell the
world that a right-wing fascist way of doing
things doesn't work then no one will listen
to me so I'm going to make a perfect fascist
World everyone is beautiful everyone is shiny
everyone has big guns and fancy ships but
it's only good for killing [__] bugs yeah
it is yeah that is the world that he created
yeah yeah he's succeeded I mean that's the
way we treat him when we were going to War
2 just crush them like they're bugs crushed
them like they're bugs and we are you know
the elite we're beautiful and we are Mighty
and yeah we're shiny we will come and bring
the lights to whatever we touch our boots
down on uh wow this was crazy yeah man so
many trivias well guys I thought this was
a really fun movie with a much more interesting
take with a production design it still helds
up really well but some fun performances to
be had and I wonder what the sequels ultimately
pan out to be better than some schlockfest
so we'll watch them all are they good are
they highly revered uh you know maybe part
three is okay the guy if they got van Deen
back I doubt it which I've seen him in person
okay so they have made a direct Starship Troopers
too okay yeah these must be straight to part
three straight to DVDs right God 1997. damn
12 12 audience audience score that's a bummer
how is it so bad that is so bad the the critics
score is higher that's 33 Starship Troopers
three 50 critic score but but 19 audience
score but the caveat is only six critics reviewed
each of these movies oh yes so so you have
a way larger pool of uh viewer reviews okay
Starship Troopers one not as as fresh on both
accounts Starship Troopers invasion the animated
one is better liked by audiences for sure
oh traders of Mars sound is it cost effective
these days to do these CG movies for stuff
like this I have no idea oh but Casper Van
Dean and Dina Meyer came back to do voices
that's cool so maybe her character lives I
guess maybe yeah maybe they'll do some retcon
oh he's got the eye patch yeah damn Rico I'm
not sure we should watch them all we should
report back Troopers binge guys that's right
we will rank them all and let you know which
one's the best God Denise Richards yeah man
back in the Heyday it was like I did not know
I did not realize you you were the queen that's
right man just before Undercover Brother she
is before still pretty hot yeah no she's she's
a little little plastic surgery it happens
it happens it happens it's now more than ever
it happens when you're in this world when
you're on planet Earth and you're a woman
in Hollywood a little over Botox you know
you know what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do what's the one I'm saying do you
know do you know what Dina my I don't think
you're right about that you are hey hey hey
hey she's aged gracefully she looks good still
but she looks natural yeah gray gray it's
got some Grays going on it's all good rock
that silver rock that silver oh Denise Richards
are still friends dude all right let's get
them all back together difficult to choose
reunion I know and especially back then they're
both so electric they're both they both had
it it's real you know that is the perfect
like they live in he goes like you go to Harvard
the Ulta he's got all the money yeah I know
it was in the best part of the capitalist
Society Embraces at all go to war fight for
your country doesn't it that's a wild movie
it's kind of uh yeah yeah it's like the whole
time I was like I don't know what these bugs
did just because it's out here being it doesn't
sound like being bugs don't go bother them
that's it and if they come your way deal with
that but it just felt like doesn't need to
be anymore like why they don't even fight
I don't I don't care why they're fighting
there's no need for them to fight that's seen
one of their I wonder I truly wonder if those
were real roaches where the kids that one
shower the kids are stomping on the roaches
and it may reminded me of Men In Black that
whole like you don't start nothing it ain't
gonna be nothing you know well then when they're
um like when the cameraman too is also like
zooming in like when the person's being killed
and they're just like [__] recording up
close just reminded me a nope like just yeah
that uh more cells what can you do yeah whatever
you do don't stop filming I wonder if they
had the I I really wonder if those roaches
were real they're they're rules about that
probably There are rules about bug actors
on screen you can't kill bugs on screen alrighty
guys well what do you think of Starship Troopers
leave your thoughts down below subscribe leave
a like Hey listen to the patron of the day
shout out
Andrew Hayes we said who the hell are we shouting
out for Starship Troopers and uh we ain't
have to look at the list we said who will
we want on our team to go out there and kill
some bugs I'm gonna kill some big bucks Starship
Troopers Andrew Hayes over here you just if
you know this guy short stocky fella he can
go in there run you can see him running up
that hill with his tiny little legs
punch you in the face
get some that's Andrew Hayes out there fighting
some bugs man just had to survive a bug apocalypse
dude Andrew uh I never hear from you anymore
but you stay pledged uh at the at that one
of our highest levels forever that's just
a loyal citizen of the reject nation and the
kind of person you want as part of your army
when you're traveling across space trying
to murder some creatures that that they deserve
it they absolutely did everything so Andrew
hope you have a merry Christmas say hi to
your family for me and you better have a damn
good new year because if you don't I'm kicking
in that door saying quit having a [__]
Year and have a great year have a glow up
a love use [Music]